North Dakota senator Heidi Heitkamp is
apologizing for a campaign ad that
publicly identified sexual assault
survivors without their permission and
wrongly named others the Democrat facing
a tough re-election fight ran the
newspaper ad while trying to explain to
voters why she opposed justice Brett
Kavanaugh is confirmation at O'Keefe is
on Capitol Hill at good morning good
morning John at least 22 of the women
say they didn't give their consent to be
involved in this and they're threatening
legal action saying that pike cams
campaign may have actually violated
state privacy laws the ad ran in some
North Dakota newspapers over the weekend
it was addressed as an open letter to
high camps Republican opponent Kevin
Cramer it read we're here to let you
know that we have all suffered from
domestic violence sexual assault or rape
and that yes we expect somebody to
believe us when we say it in a statement
the women said hi Kemp's political
agenda has interfered with or downright
ruined our lives in some cases the women
said they had to reassure family they've
never been assaulted or raped for her
part Heitkamp is deeply apologetic CBS
News obtained one of the voicemail she
left for a wrongly identified woman take
a listen hi this is Heidi Heitkamp I
don't know if you want to talk to me or
not
but I wanted to extend a personal
apology and just want to spend just a
few minutes just talking to you I'm so
mortified and horrified and I can
completely appreciate if you don't want
to hear from me
now high-camp is one of those 10
Democratic senators running for
re-election this year in a red state and
right now she's seen it's most at risk
because polling suggests she's trailing
Kramer John ed O'Keefe thank you ad